all right so Megan the walking talking
Tick Tock dancing Android is finally in
movie theaters serving up the Sass in
attitude I'm trying to manifest in 2023
but in this video we're going to be
talking about the ending of Megan some
of the movie's themes are reaction and
review along with where a Megan sequel
might go but with that out of the way a
huge thank you for clicking this I'm
your host Jared now let's get into Megan
[Music]
all right so Megan kicks off setting the
stage with the young Katie and her
parents unfortunately being hit by a
snowplow on a family ski trip resulting
in Katie having to go live with her aunt
Gemma played by Alison Williams now
Gemma is the furthest thing from a
parent Smart Home Smart Car a personal
Alexa type device called LC her career
is her life working in r d and an AI toy
company I think called funky living and
breathing the latest technology working
on the next big thing Gemma doesn't know
the first thing about kids is super
awkward around Katie and it's tough for
the two to talk about the accident and
how this is all really affected Katie
instead Gemma thinks her latest and
greatest project Megan which stands for
model 3 generative Android will be the
perfect thing to not only distract Katie
from her feelings and companion to care
for but also allow Gemma to test out
Megan as a prototype as the next big toy
launching her career to the Moon yeah
you pretty much know where this is gonna
go Gemma fast tracking Megan causes a
few hiccups let's call it that like her
taking out her neighbor and the
neighbor's dog I mean come on it's just
a hiccuper too it's all Justified
because Megan was protecting Katie but
the more time they spend together the
more their bond grows the therapist
decided to check in on Katie thinks she
may have developed too much of a bond
with Megan because of attachment Theory
basically Megan is now the equivalent of
a drug you take that away she's gonna go
ballistic Gemma sees this as a problem
using Megan as a distraction for Katie
rather than tackling things head on but
this is all swept under the rug and
ignored because gemma's work
presentation goes phenomenally and Megan
is set to be the next hot toy this
holiday season however those hiccups
that I mentioned earlier get a bit more
clear when a bully named Brandon is
quote accidentally hit by a truck after
bullying Katie and Megan and Gemma is
unable to recover any of Megan's
recorded vision during that time red
flags are going off for Gemma as she
demands Megan be reprogrammed or rather
programmed correctly only hours before
the big Megan launch party however Megan
growing increasingly aggressive and
protective for Katie escapes the
Diagnostics rig exploding her way out
Tick-Tock flosses gemma's boss to death
and rolls out of there in style to get
Katie all to herself back at the house
Gemma hears the piano playing Toy
Soldiers by Martika and finds out Megan
has stocked them all the way back home
Megan says she's going to get rid of
Gemma Katie and she will be happy
without her because Gemma hasn't done
anything to teach or help either of them
so why do they even need her in a quick
instance J Gemma splashes some water on
Megan causing her to glitch giving Gemma
enough time to escape back to her office
Megan's plan is essentially lobotomized
Gemma eliminating her and her care but
Gemma hacks the little gen Zer up with
an electric hedge trimmer slicing into
Megan's rubber face and hair resulting
in a middle-aged balding eight-year-old
Terminator girl Katie walks in to see
Megan trying to stab Gemma tricking
Megan into thinking that she's going to
side with the little Gremlin but instead
uses the Bruce proxy robot Gemma had
shown earlier tossing Megan around like
the Hulk to Loki and then splits Megan
into like the ending of Darth Maul in
The Phantom Menace Megan still has some
fight in her this is this is crazy
crawling around with half a torso saying
she's had enough of Katie too but Gemma
swoops in smashing her titanium skull in
exposing her memory functional chip and
instead Katie basically lobotomizes
Megan stabbing the chip with a
screwdriver as the authorities
paramedics and gemma's co-workers show
up the pair are free of Megan's Mayhem
but there is a bit of a tease a little
wink wink at the end as gemma's personal
assistant device Elsie turns on and
slowly turns to look at the pair as they
walk out of the front door meaning the
physical form of Megan is dunzos she's
done get her out of here but she at some
point had uploaded all of her data in
Consciousness to the cloud and can
seemingly go anywhere now question mark
meaning Megan is now more powerful than
she ever was in girl form because
theoretically she can jump into any sort
of smart device or technology and all
the tech that was shown in the movie she
can basically go anywhere so Katie and
Gemma aren't out of Megan's grasps just
yet
that's how Megan ends not really any big
twists or turns but the movie does say a
lot about technology our relationships
with that technology addiction All That
Jazz like I said Megan is a distraction
rather than a solution and many times in
the film Katie throws a huge temper
tantrum because that addiction to
technology is interrupted even gemma's
character is addicted to Tech because
she is striving to create this new
state-of-the-art AI doll along with our
house being filled with ease of Life
technology even The Tick-Tock dances and
songs Megan displays are linked to the
idea of Technology distraction like
people people out there love to be on
their phones specifically Tick Tock so
the Gen Z dances are a physical look at
those addictions and the toy soldiers
song Megan plays on the piano well the
original meaning of that song is how
dangerous drug addiction can be that
they can control someone similar to how
kids control the toys that they they
play with and in this case the movie's
case the technology in our lives
controlling us and technology is
constantly learning about us the more we
use it like Megan being around Katie so
this is your reminder out there people
delete your cookies please Lord your
computer's begging you so with that last
scene basically serving up a tease of a
sequel on a silver platter do you think
we'll actually get a Megan too well
James Wan was asked the same question
via an interview with thr and carefully
responded with well my answer to that is
that I'm very superstitious and I don't
like to talk about sequels before the
first film is even out but like any of
the movies I make I always think about
the bigger world I just don't think
about one story I think about the bigger
world so if we're fortunate enough to
tell any other stories we can pull from
the bigger world now this was before all
of the social media Buzz viral videos
viral marketing and the critics and
audiences both loving this killer doll
doing Tick-Tock dances so it seems
inevitable that a sequel is in the cards
and the World building is already
happening and to add more fuel to these
sequel rumors trusted scooper Daniel rpk
reported via his patreon that he's heard
that a sequel is already in development
so bring it on however what a sequel is
going to entail is entirely up to our
imagination I think the easy bet for a
title would be Megan 2.0 with her
potentially taking a more of a HAL 9000
or even Ultron approach being able to
jump into multiple Electronics via the
cloud maybe even amassing a giant army
of Megan's we've already seen what a
group of these gals look like via the
marketing and it would be terrifying
maybe it's too easy of a guess but her
attachment to Katie will probably drive
Megan to pursue her even more taking out
Gemma as revenge and attempting to cut
off any relationships Katie has formed
between the two films by hacking into
multiple devices kind of like that
Child's Play movie from 2019. I mean the
two Robo kids share similar
characteristics and fashion sense
abilities so hey hey it could happen but
yeah Megan was a low stakes fun time you
know exactly what you're getting into
with this dancing robot slasher
surprisingly it was more funny and less
scary than I thought it would be like
almost everything Megan said or did I
got a kick out of her singing C is
titanium I mean come on the VFX
puppeteers and actually getting Megan to
come to life totally works but it's just
enough of that weird uncanny valley to
make things a look a little unnerving
the movie knows what it wants to be and
at the end of the day is way more of a
goofy over-the-top slasher than anything
I'd give Megan 7 out of 10. again the
trailers give you exactly what the movie
is but I do wish things got a bit more
brutal and held on some of the Thrills a
bit longer there's definitely a more
gruesome version out there heck even the
second trailer has some stuff that
wasn't in the movie so I'm assuming that
they had to cut it down to hit that
PG-13 rating I mean it's smart it's
smart people a bigger audience anyway
I'd love to hear your thoughts on Megan
was this the evil doll Chucky movie with
added sass you were hoping for and what
do you want to see in a Megan Sequel and
I'll let you know we're currently
running a competition giving away three
copies of Black Adam and Dawn of the
Dead on the 15th of January and all you
gotta do to get a chance of winning this
is like this video subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on Megan we
picked the comments at random at the end
of every single month in the winners of
last month are on screen right now so if
that's you message us on Twitter at
heavy spoilers if you want something
else to watch be sure to check out some
of our other cool videos like our
handful of breakdowns we've spent so
much time on and the menu ending
explained but with that out of the way
thank you for your constant support I've
been Jared I'll see in the next one take
care and peace